global warming is real it's man-made it
is a problem that we need to fix but
just like we shouldn't say it's not
happening
we shouldn't over and exaggerate it and
say it's going to be the end of the
world global warming is going to be a
problem we estimate it's going to cost
about half a percentage point of the GDP
of the 21st century that's substantial
but not the end of the world
we asked some of the world's top climate
economists what are the best ways to fix
climate they told us the best long-term
way is by dramatically increasing
investment in research and development
of green energy they said spend a
hundred billion dollars or about 0.2
percent of global GDP every year that's
about 50 times more than what the world
spends today
it's a great question because businesses
only have a limited amount of money to
spend and they have to ask very clearly
what is it we can do to attain
sustainability very often we go for
grand gestures and stuff that looks good
in the press but in reality we have to
ask ourselves where do we help humans
where do we help the future most look
for instance if you spend your money on
cutting back carbon emissions the
typical cost is at least a couple of
dollars and very likely twenty or even a
hundred dollars per ton of co2 saved
that means you ain't very easily end up
doing less good than the money you spent
had you spent the same amount of money
on some of the things where you could do
immense amounts of good for instance
clean drinking water or sanitation or
basic health care you can do ten to
twenty to forty times as much good as
the money you spend so spend it where
your business says you can do extra good
coca-cola for instance those focusing on
spending it on clean drinking water that
makes great sense of course the choices
for us are very nuanced and very complex
and we'd love to do it all but we don't
we don't actually fix all problems in
the world and so we've got to ask
ourselves how do we want to be
remembered spending it well that is
doing the most good we could with the
money we spent or just doing some good I
would hope that we want to do the most
good possible that includes asking how
much do you get back if you invest in an
hiv/aids how much do you get if you
invest it in micronutrient deficiencies
and how much do you get if you cut a ton
of carbon emissions if we can do much
more good by spending it on some of the
less interesting more mundane but
ultimately much more beneficial areas
don't we have a moral moral
responsibility to do so
we asked some of the world's top
economists across all different areas
ask them to identify what are the
biggest problems for the world and what
are the best solutions to those problems
but not only that also tell us how much
does it cost and how much good does it
do now if you say it's gonna cost a
billion but it'll actually do twenty
billion worth of social good the benefit
cost ratio is one to twenty for every
dollar spent you do $20 worth of good
that's a great investment and it makes
it very easy for us to understand how we
spending the money to do the most good
so these are estimates from some of the
world's top economists across the board
and they will help us make decisions on
how to spend our money in the best
possible way
cold economic facts don't change the
world by themselves we need political
will but I'm hoping the cold economic
facts can inform that political decision
so we don't just make the easy feel-good
politically correct decisions but we
actually focus on the things where we
can do immense amounts of good first